ce soir donc mis en question de jacques
attali
33 ans
maître des requêtes au conseil d'état
professeur à l'école polytechnique et à
l'université paris dauphine
conseiller de françois mitterrand
écrivain enfin
écrivain surtout
qui refuse les étiquettes
et qui dit il ne sait pas se regarder
dans le miroir
méfie beaucoup de cette idée
d'autoportraits
d'abord parce que c'est pas vraiment un
autoportrait contrôle pas grand chose ni
la caméra ni le montage ils rythment
unis ni l'outil je suis quelqu'un qui
aime le travail solitaire l'effort
physique solitaire
ensuite parce qu'un autoportrait c'est
inévitablement rentrer dans un jeu de ce
spectacle qui met en avant les éléments
les plus anecdotiques d'une personnalité
fait passer des idées au second plan
derrière nous fait que un intellectuel
c'est évidemment un homme comme un autre
avec ses passions ses faiblesses ses
risques ces remises en cause
et donc qui nous fait entrer dans ce
monde du spectacle les idées les plus
élémentaires
sont camouflés derrière la vie
quotidienne et et le modèle qu'on peut
représenter pour un groupe social ou
quelques individus
et enfin parce que
tout montrait signifierait pouvoir
cristallisé sa propre personnalité à un
moment donné avoir envie de dire je suis
cela
ce qui me paraît dément
on n'est rien sinon
quelque chose qui passe et qui changent
à chaque instant et moi plus
particulièrement aujourd'hui je me sens
en état de très profond transition
plutôt un homme à question qu'un homme
en question c'est à dire avoir beaucoup
envie aujourd'hui de réfléchir et de
changes et sur les rapports entre
l'intellectuel qui écrit et qui
réfléchit et qui a envie de se faire
entendre et du politique qui est le lieu
privilégié aujourd'hui de l'action mais
qui aussi canalise transforme réduit
met en scène le discours ne le fait
entendre que lorsqu'il sert trop souvent
à l'anecdote et aux débats quotidiens
voilà le risque et voilà l'enjeu voilà
pourquoi je suis très
anxieux de ce qui va suivre est plutôt
avec envie de faire un une longue
interrogations sur
le rapport entre l'intellectuel et le
pouvoir le pouvoir l intellectuel plutôt
que de jouer ce jeu d'un autoportrait
qu'en fait je ne contrôlais pas
jacques attali le haut fonctionnaire qui
siège au conseil d'état
l'enseignant de dauphine et de lixhe
l'écrivain de lentilles économique de la
parole est l'outil de bruit
l'amateur de musique
l'un des conseillers
françois mitterrand et peut-être que
j'en oublie
ou et son unité son unité profonde
ce serait très difficile d'essayer de
rationaliser sur sa propre action sa
propre vie qui est toujours quoique on
essaie de la tenir et je fais tout ce
que je peux pour essayer de la tenir une
succession de de hasard et et de fait
bon j'essaie de trouver d'une construire
une unité dans le sentiment que j'ai que
nous sommes dans une période dans lequel
il est hors de question
de
pouvoir penser une action sans une
réflexion complètement navet qui exige
du temps et du travail
d'autre part je trouve mon plaisir
personnel je vois la plus profonde à
enseigner et à écrire et j'ai toujours
cherché des façons de communiquer aussi
diverses que possible lié à un temps qui
exigent des façons de communiquer les
lieux de communication de deschamps l'a
fait de plus riche le plus intéressant
et le plus porteur d'avenir
problématique méthodologique le plus
intéressant en matière de résultats
quant à l'analyse marxiste la crise
alors mon action est essentiellement
tourné autour de la recherche de
différentes façons de communiquer et de
communiquer des réflexions sur une
angoisse très profonde que je c'est à
dire que si les transformations très
neuf quant à leur nature à leur
perception à leur conception quant à
leur profondeur je crois bien plus de
comportements que deux d'institutions et
bien il est clair que nos civilisations
cours à un retour de la barbarie
formidable rapide destructeur broyeur
considérable et au fond j'ai un peu le
sentiment de ne chercher face à une
citadelle enfermé cloisonné
barbelés différentes portes d'entrée en
sachant qu'il ya peut-être plusieurs et
que nous sommes ne suis pas là
l'enseignement est peut-être là le
fondamental bien que c'est au niveau des
enseignements primaires ou maternelles
qu'il faudrait âgées la politique est le
plus court moyen le raccourci pour
l'action et il est clair qu'il faudra
entrer dans cette option mais si j'avais
à faire une hiérarchie dans mon travail
je dirais que pour moi l'essentiel c'est
laquelle j'attache une importance c'est
l'écriture d'abord pour une raison
simple c'est que
je suis obsédé par le temps qui passe
comme tout le monde mais peut-être
beaucoup
et que un livre c'est du temps
cristallisé c'est c'est le sentiment de
ce que un temps qui a passé à une forme
d'éternité
peut-être que pour une femme fait
d'avoir un enfant je veux le même rôle
que pour un écrivain le niveau qu'il a
produit mais pour moi c'est 7 centimes
ans de lutte contre l'absurde de titan
lutte absurde comme toute lutte face à
l'absurde
et qui en même temps se situe dans une
période dans lequel communiqué par
l'écriture joue un rôle important parce
que encore une fois il ne faut pas se
contenter d'appliquer des schémas loose
une crise d'une ampleur telle qu'elle ne
trouve pas des solutions des schémas
qu'il suffirait de mettre en oeuvre
voilà c'est une façon de vouloir parler
de toutes les façons possibles pour ce
qui est de la buse de la concurrence du
capital
le capitalisme est présenté comme étant
une structure aux yeux du public pour
qui vous êtes et je dis bien et
j'insiste entre guillemets le conseiller
économique de françois mitterrand est ce
que cette image unique ne vous agace pas
un peu
oui elle magway sais elle me pose
problème d'abord parce que à l'égard de
françois mitterrand je ne suis pas son
seul conseiller je ne voudrais en aucune
façon que qui que ce soit puisse penser
à comment s'est lui-même que j'essaye de
me faire entendre à l'ombre de ce grand
personnage
j'ai le grand privilège d'être écoutés
de lui et de travailler à ses côtés je
m'en sens très heureux et c'est très
important pour moi ça donne un sens à
mon travail mais je voudrais être
entendu pour ce que je suis c'est à dire
surtout pour ce que j'écris et ensuite
je ne voudrais pas que soient mélangées
le spectacle de la politique
l'engagement quotidien et la bataille
concrètes que cela signifie avec la
liberté d'un intellectuel qui doit avoir
le droit de douter d'avoir tort de
changer d'avis de ne pas parler et de
rester un peu lointains par rapport à
l'action donc c'est d'avoir les deux
mais je voudrais être moi même et que
mon action auprès de son personnage que
j'admire et que je respecte lequel je
suis très heureux de travailler ne soit
qu'une des parties de ma personnalité
comme ça l'est pour lui même qu'une
toute petite partie de son environnement
intellectuel donc vous êtes bien
conscient que vous êtes de quelques
façons par cette appellation l'âme un
peu mythifié je suis censuré c'est à
dire que on ne m'entend que par le poids
politique imaginaire que peut avoir les
idées que j'ai mais je suis très tout à
fait lucide sur le fait qu'on me lis
davantage parce qu'on cherche en
filigrane ce qui a peut y avoir de
porter politique et je ne le nie pas
j'en suis très très heureux dans mon
disque au plus que par les idées de même
que je peux développer
j'en suis très très heureux pour ce que
cela peut avoir de de résonance sur mon
propre discours mais j'en suis un peu
inquiet et c'est pourquoi j'essaye de
bien séparer de la réduction de
l'intellectuel à sa dimension politique
est une façon d'anecdotes ise ou de
censurer son travail ou ce qu'il a à
dire ceci dit j'ai je crois que
l'intellectuel qui travaillent sur le
pouvoir qui nie le pouvoir comme c'est
très à la mode dans ce que j'appelle moi
la nouvelle droite française qui se
prêtent un gauchiste mais qui en fait
une nouvelle droite est une façon en
fait de critiquer le fait qu'ils ne sont
pas entendus par les pouvoirs et le fait
qu'ils n'ont pas de prise sur le pouvoir
et je crois que intellectuelle qui
aujourd'hui ne veut pas entrer dans la
bataille concrètes quotidiennes de la
construction du socialisme et de la
démystification de ce que la droite veut
faire croire que le socialisme n'est
qu'un intellectuel de droite parce qu'il
est inactif parce qu il est donc hors de
la transformation quotidienne concrète
d'une société donnée celle où nous
sommes historiquement placé et donc je
suis tout à fait à l'aise et heureux
d'avoir cette double dimension mais qui
exige dans l'un comme dans l'autre une
assez longue bataille pour se faire
entendre et comme intellectuels et des
dents mais dans l'action par rapport à
ceux qui n'ont pas ce dont status de
cette division du travail entre cantons
l'intellectuel de production ou des
branches ont dû capital avec lequel ils
produisent investissent et organise
n'élève la rentabilisation et la mise en
valeur du capital
ces branches à certaines périodes ont
des croissances
[Musique]
je vais devenir
la compétition
je vais
et
à la fin parce que s'est créé des
catastrophes et c'est délire de
catastrophes chasse
[Musique]
non ça il est là par hasard mais
toujours été très heureux de ma
maladresse parce que c'est grâce à elle
plutôt grâce à ma mère dans sa réaction
sur marc allard est ce que je dois
d'avoir découvert la musique puisque
c'est pour me défendre de vendre est ce
qu'on va me à 14 heures devant un piano
abouchi toujours aussi maladroit
je suis heureux que vous parliez de
votre mère parce que ça va nous
permettre de parler quand même de votre
enfance de savoir qui vous êtes vous
venu où vous êtes né
je fais partie de cette
communauté juive d'algérie en racines et
dans le monde arabe depuis des siècles
mais ayant gardé sa grande autonomie sa
grande indépendance sa culture et est
devenue française depuis plus d'un
siècle et qui peu à peu à
vis des échelons de l'art de la culture
et de la libyan être épique peu à peu
s'est intégré dans la vie culturelle et
politique française j'ai eu la grande
chance de d'être
revenu en france très jeune j'avais 12
ans 1 quelle année mais la 156 qui tend
de 3 ans
et d'avoir donc fait des études en
algérie dans un monde très français plus
la communauté française en algérie était
très coupé du monde l'a beaucoup plus
que dans la halle au maroc ou en tunisie
et d'être à l'âge de 12 ans venus ici
quittant le soleil la mer est tout ce
que ça représente et pour devenir un
vrai parisien je n'ai plus quitté paris
depuis depuis l'âge de 12 ans j'ai vécu
une enfance donc de rêve dans ce monde
de soleil et de paix puisque c'était
encore la paix bien que mon anniversaire
se situe le jour du démarrage de la
guerre premier neuf ans et que j'ai des
souvenirs extrêmement précis de ces de
ces phénomènes qui ont marqué mon
enfance et plus tard ma jeunesse
et les conflits politiques que ça
représentait la fois pour ma famille mon
père est un homme très très libéral j'ai
toujours été persuadé que
les conséquences de la forme qu avait
pris la colonisation française
conduisent inévitablement à
l'indépendance algérienne
et donc j'ai trouvé que c'est un gosse
libéral en vivent aussi profondément les
conséquences que cela pourrait avoir
pour
pour ma famille elle même et pour ce
monde de gens qui n'avaient pas voulu ni
ni su ce que la colonisation faisait
peser sur sur les algériens j'entends le
peuple français des petits commerçants
ouvriers
qui vivaient là l'algérie comme leurs
peuples leur pays et leurs terres et
aujourd'hui comment vous ressentez ce
cette séparation de vos racines vous
savez je n'ai jamais été très attiré par
par les souvenirs mais par le passé
je n'ai jamais eu l'occasion ni cherché
à susciter
jusque très récemment le désir de
retourner en algérie
je ne me sens pas attacher véritablement
a des racines là plutôt qu'ailleurs
peut-être est-ce que ce déracinement
s'ajoute à celui que tout juif connaît
c'est à dire le sentiment d'être partout
d'abord au delà d'un acteur plein et
anti un observateur
historiquement depuis très longtemps me
sens dans cette situation d' observateur
passionné par l'action c'est un peu une
contradiction profonde que j'ai
peut-être mais cette cette aliénation
sens anglais du mot sans ce libéral du
mot c'est à dire cette extériorité je la
ressens à la fois comme comme comme
louis fhcom mais elle dans un pays
étranger et non seulement étrangers une
main pays qui n'existe plus une fois
c'est même pas un pays qu'on pourrait
retrouver en y retournant il n'existe
plus il a disparu il est devenu fantôme
et que qui a vient compléter
l'extériorité inévitable de
l'intellectuel dans l'action
[Musique]
quelques questions emprunté au
dictionnaire de proust
l'oiseau que vous préférez
c'est très loin de la nature je ne
saurais bien
encore une fois un objet avec un souffle
guy
lafleur que vous aimez
je n'y connais rien
la couleur que vous préférez le bleu
clair
le pays où désireriez vivre
là où je suis
ce que vous voudriez être
ce que j'espère que je serai imaginez
vous votre avenir
oui mais je ne le dirai pas
quel serait votre plus grand malheur
me rendre compte trop tard que j'ai
vieilli
[Musique]
votre rêve de bonheur ce qu'un mot que
je ne comprends pas
votre occupation préférée
toutes celles où j'ai l'impression
d'être en situation de me dépasser moi
même c'est à dire dans mes rapports avec
les gens ou dans l'écriture tous les
moments où j'ai l'impression vraiment de
d'aller plus loin que ce que je crois
être
votre principal défaut
une certaine forme de culpabilisation
permanente à l'égard de ce que
ce que je suis ce que je voudrais c'est
ce qui doit certainement gênés beaucoup
de gens autour de moi
ce que vous appréciez le plus chez vos
amis
la franchise
la qualité que vous préférez chez une
femme
qu'elle soit inattendu
la qualité que vous désirez chez un
homme
la même chose
vaut auteurs favoris
ça change du jour en jour du désert ou
des jo j'ai envie de lire des choses
sérieuses d'autre part donc je n'ai pas
de deux stars à mettre sur un piédestal
même question pour les musiciens même
réponse
le principal trait de votre caractère
j'ai l'impression mon caractère change
beaucoup en ce moment donc je ne saurais
définir toute façon je ne sais pas me
regardera jamais
[Musique]
complètement au contraire de la théorie
classique que ça n'est pas la
concurrence qui permet de rétablir la
stabilité des prix l'économie n'est
qu'au contraire c'est la concurrence qui
est la cause de la crise
[Musique]
non
dans les statistiques de l'économie
américaine il faut bien voir donc que la
logique
du processus et d'expliquer la crise par
l'existence même de la concurrence
et qu'au contraire de la théorie
néoclassique là conclut j'essaye en
semaine écrire
quelque chose sur eux ben qu'est ce que
peut-être on a socialisme dans un temps
or il se trouve que dans 20 ans et c'est
le début du xxième
réseau n'est pas raisonné du tout non
j'ai
c'est le l'envi d'écrire sur ce que sera
dans vingt ans l'absurde parce que les
chances que le monde soit absurde sont
plus grandes que celles qu'ils soient
raisonnables le chances qu'il fasse sa
place à l'art les libertés et la
création sont moins grandes que celles
de monde de bureaucratie et de morts ce
qui est un peu la même chose et j'essaie
envie de pousser jusqu'à l'extrême
l'analyse des conséquences de
l'absurdité de la nature du problème
technique de l'absurdité du goût de
compétition par rapport aux autres
solidarité de l'absurdité de la racine
mandant le pouvoir quel qu'il soit sous
des formes de plus en plus atroces
et je crois qu'il n'y a plus de profiter
de raisonnable aujourd'hui il n'y a
qu'un prophétisme de l'absurde qui
montre à quel point le nombre de chances
d'avoir un an
vivable et dérisoire donc l'urgence
aujourd'hui d'entreprendre sa mise en
oeuvre je crois que s'ils voulaient que
aujourd'hui être le prophétisme
ccc se mesure à l'ampleur de l'action
quotidienne parce que au fond on a une
fantastique aveuglement à l'égard de cet
avenir qui se construit tous les jours à
chaque instant chaque instant on fait du
long terme bon
et
écrire sur l'absurde de l'avenir c'est
un peu une façon d'entraîner peut-être
davantage de d'actions quotidiennes pour
en éviter qu'il ne le soit mais c'est
pas spécialement optimiste
je pense très très certainement que les
chances de ce que nous évitions les
innombrables catastrophe qui parsèment
les 20 ans qui viennent
avec ce qu'elles ont de concentration de
pouvoirs de totalitarisme de
bureaucratie de monopolisation du
pouvoir par une minorité de
dépersonnalisation sont pas très grands
qu'à côté de ça les espérances qui
naissent et le renouveau intellectuel et
culturel dans la jeunesse est formidable
mais que le choc entre les deux
il n'est pas pensé dès aujourd'hui comme
un véritable
enjeu de survie de l'humanité a peu de
chances de t'être
transformer en de façon façon positive
alors je crois que c'est il faut
recommencer à parler du très très long
terme il faut commencer à en parler il
faut plus faut pas avoir peur mais des
périodes c'est curieux que les périodes
de transformation comme ça sont plus des
périodes où on pense à faire des
encyclopédies qu'à faire des livres sur
l'avenir on pense plus à faire la
synthèse de ce qu'il faut conserver du
passé plutôt qu'à penser le long terme
pour nos sociétés se caractérise plus
par ses arches de noé avant le déluge
que par la prophétisme sur ce qui
viendra après de l'élu et c'est
peut-être parce que on ne le fait pas
assez on ne le pense pas assez que
viendront les loges
bien jacques attali vous ne terminez pas
par des notes très optimiste est ce que
françois mitterrand est aussi pessimiste
que vous allez lui demander
c'est donc maintenant le temps des
questions et la première posée par andré
glucksmann chercheur au cnrs et qui
vient de publier les maîtres penseurs
andré glucksmann on va dire je suis un
peu embarrassé c'est l'ordre
alphabétique qui veut que je pousse deux
premiers question en fait je m'interroge
parce que votre film ne permet pas
tellement de poser des questions parce
qu'ils n'en pose pas tellement le mignon
qui venaient d'algérie et vous ne parlez
pas de la guerre d'algérie vous êtes à
mimi tran vous avez pris des positions
son programme commun se divise la france
ça divise la gauche et s'est il pas un
mot vous parlez de votre angoisse vous
parlez du socialisme mais pas un mot de
ce qui angoisse dans le socialisme à
savoir le goulag le cambodge finalement
vous dites je mène une bataille
concrètes quotidiennes
il ya rien de quotidiens et rien de
concret dans ce que nous venons de voir
alors une question est ce que dans tout
ce que vous avez dit et montré à l'écran
vous qui faites à ce que vous dites une
différence entre la gauche et la droite
est ce que vous pensez qu'il ya une
seule phrase une seule pensée une seule
idée qui n'aurait pu être énoncé soit
par valéry giscard d'estaing soit par un
interfit
d'abord comme dans la vie on se tutoie
j'ai du mal à employer le théâtre qui
consiste à vous vous voyez
je dirais simplement que
je me suis situé à l'évidence que je
suis c'est à dire comme un homme de
gauche et je crois que la
caractéristique fondamentale d'un homme
de gauche d'un intellectuel de gauche
c'est de penser que la mise en scène du
pouvoir politique telle qu'elle est
aujourd'hui et la collusion entre le
pouvoir économique et le pouvoir
politique doit être aboli ceci étant dit
c'est dans ce camp que je me suis placé
c'est de là que j'ai parlé rien de ce
que j'aurais pu dire dans un tel film
qui est inévitablement des côtes et qui
me gêne aussi narcissique ou ou
intimistes comme ça ne peut être repris
à mon sens dans une perspective de
conservation du pouvoir je crois au
contraire que la grande caractéristique
qui sépare un intellectuel de gauche
parle intellectuels de droite c'est ce
qu'il dit au sujet du pouvoir et c'est
ce qu'il dit et c'est ce qu'il fait au
sujet du pouvoir je crois pas en
particulier que lorsqu'on nous dit que
un pays est socialiste et que le
socialisme est en cause par le goulag ce
n'est pas être de gauche parce qu'à
l'évidence les pays où il existe le
goulag ne sont pas les pays socialistes
donc dire cela ce que vous avez fait
d'une parenthèse à mon avis et ses potes
du tome le compliment c'est en fait être
de droite
guy lardreau hauteur de langer
professeur de philo au lycée d'auxerre
oui j'avais préparé une question mais
qui s'avère sans intérêt par rapport à
ce que vient de dire attali alors en
réponse à glucksmann alors je vais donc
leur questionné sur sa réponse ils
viennent dire que finalement ça n'avait
pas de sens de mettre en cause de
socialisme à travers les pays qui se
disent socialistes parce que à
l'évidence dit il ces pays ne sont pas
socialistes premier boeing m'accordera
que ce n'est pas une évidence parce que
quand même se le dise il seul programme
suffisamment fort il ya quand même
suffisamment de gens qui y croient bon
donc un ce n'est pas une évidence 2
je vis je lui tire est je pense qu'il
sera d'accord avec moi que finalement
maintenant pour nous
le créateur du socialisme ses marques
non pas qu'il y aurait eu qu'il n'y
aurait pas eu plutôt un socialisme non
marxiste ou très marxiste mais il se
trouve que de fait marque ça
complètement raréfier comme ça le
socialisme et qu'en réalité aujourd'hui
marxisme et socialisme sont deux mots et
yves alors je suppose qu'ils me
l'accordera non non bon toujours c'est
non mais peu importe nous dans la
question continue parce que ça ça n'a
pas d'importance je suis heureux et je
prends note vient de dire mais ma
question continue quoi qu'il en soit il
m'accorde re alors ça je suppose que
pour l'immense majorité des français à
seulement des français les deux termes
sont équivalents mais non les français
ne s'y on parle de l'immense majorité ne
savent pas ce qu'est la pensée de marx y
pense le socialisme en des termes de
justice sociale en dtm de transformation
de l'inégalité de transformation de
privilèges je vais répondre à cette
question je réponds à cette question non
parce que la question n'a pas été posée
la question n'a pas été posée au fond
cela vous savez que c'est dans le jeu
des questions brèves visites admettez
vous admettez vous un gars comme l'un
des critères
d'une philosophie socialiste secret
perte de fait était celui de marx mais
après tout blargies dire considéré qu'il
ne faut pas pour marthe wingles puisque
la formulation et de engels c'est à dire
qu'on connaît le pudding en le goûtant
autrement dit que la pratique c'est un
critère
parce que si vous l'admettrez et alors
là après je vous laisse la parole si
vous l'admettrez une somme tout de même
léger
il nous sommes tout de même les jets
d'eau refusé de juger le socialisme sur
les seules réalisations
qu'ils en aient des effets de par le
monde et si vous mettez sous le
signifiant socialisme tout à fait autre
chose que ce qu'il y ait émis jusqu'à
l'aube alors pourquoi le gardez vous
voilà la question qui est double en
quelques jacques attali moi je ne
m'intéresse pas
disons de façon prioritaire à des débats
sur les racines idéologiques d'un
concept bien que je crois qu'elle soit
importante mais elles sont plutôt
importante dans l'histoire de la pensée
plutôt que dans ce que nous avons à
faire lorsque nous avons affaire
certainement à penser une façon d'éviter
une concrétisation de bureaucratie qui
existent aussi bien dans les pays qui se
disent socialistes ou dans les pays qui
se disent patel et je crois que lorsque
un intellectuel à choisir le champ de
son action et sa pratique s'il réserve
sa pratique sa réflexion à une réflexion
de nature ils ont un historique sur le
rapport entre certains pays qui se sont
dits des socialistes dans le camp de
passer et des penseurs qui se sont dits
penseurs d'ailleurs je pense que marc
c'était plus un penseur du capitalisme
du socialisme ils sont complètement à
côté de l'essentiel qui est que nous
sommes à la fin du xxème siècle
confrontait les technologies à des
rapports de production à des modes
d'organisation du pouvoir économique et
financier à des situations concrètes
internationale qui n'ont rien à voir
avec le temps dans lequel ses pensées
marx rien à voir avec le temps dans
qu'elle s'est construit sur un féodal
isme c'est à dire contrairement à ce que
pensent et marx non pas dans un pays
capitalistes développés mère d'un pays
féodal une société qui s'est dit
socialiste c'est à dire que ces gens
excusez moi de buts allemands perdent
leur temps
l'essentiel n'est pas là l'essentiel
c'est que nous avons devant nous un
problème d'une complexité fantastique à
la fois théorique et concret qui est de
construire quelque chose qui ressemble à
la liberté et à la création de la
liberté dans un monde qui n'a rien à
voir ni théoriquement ni concrètement à
deux situations historiques celle du
temps de marx et et celle de 1917 alors
je crois que ces deux références n'ont
pas beaucoup d'intérêt ceci dit la
pensée de marx est fondamental parce
qu'elle est une dépense et qui nous sert
fondamentalement comme paradigme pour
comprendre la crise économique les
crises et son évolution elles sont
d'abord en a parmi d'autres d'autre part
les déviations de d'à propos de ce que
ce à quoi une appropriation collective
que peut conduire dans à partir d'un
monde féodal sont extrêmement
intéressante mais je vous en prie ne
considérait pas cela comme fondamental
l'essentiel ce n'est pas de sotteville
et sur une évidence c'est que un marx
n'a pas pu penser des sociétés de
technologie très développée comme celle
d'aujourd'hui 2 que ces pays de 1900 où
le socialisme s'est construit ou s'est
institué ne sont pas nos problèmes nos
préoccupations ne ressemble en rien aux
problèmes que nous avons et que donc
l'essentiel n'est pas le faire une
zoologie de ces rapports entre la pensée
et l'action il ya un siècle mais de
penser les rapports entre la pensée et
l'action aujourd'hui avec des
technologies et des modes de pensée et
donc une rapport au pouvoir complètement
différent et je dirai tout à l'heure dès
12h d'accord alors vous n'avez pas
répondu à ma deuxième question explique
pourquoi est-ce que vous gardez le
signifiant socialisme dans ces
conditions excusez moi ne reviendront
tout à l'heure nous sommes dans la
partie des questions brèves et des
réponses brèves jusqu'à présent ils ont
plutôt tendance à être langue alors ivo
malec troisième interlocuteur une
question qui va peut-être être brève oui
sauf que je vais vous la poser à vous
même parce que je suis là en tant que
musicien et la dame nature j ja du débat
aide du scénario que nous avons imaginé
de questions brèves quatre questions a
été changé dois-je être discipliné
suivent cette dramaturgie là en lice
quand la suède a oui je tombe toujours
là parce que je pose des questions en
musicien bon changeons la dame a que
gerra belloncle attali a écrit bruit
voilà donc vous aimez la musique jacques
attali vous la pratiquez et vous venez
d'écrire un livre dont la musique que
l'objet principal le personnage
principal et c'est pour ça d'ailleurs
que je suis là et j'aimerais vous poser
la question suivante
quoi que vous avez vous aviez refusé
dans votre portrait de répondre sur les
auteurs musiciens préférés
j'insisterai quand même vous demander
c'est si beau dit là dans votre réponse
que le musicien les auteurs sa chance
selon les jours aux différences c'est
vrai je comprends parfaitement mais
yat-il cas même les musiciens qui risque
un jour d'être vos préférés d'un jour où
d'autres qui ne le seront jamais oubliés
vêtements qu'elles sont le musicien les
compositeurs ou la musique que vous
aimez et quels sont les musiciens ou la
musique que vous détestez
excusez moi je ne me sens pas capable de
répondre à une question comme celle là
parce que pour moi la musique encore une
fois c'est le jem certaines musiques à
certains moments et d'autres à d'autres
je n'exclus pas d'aimer un jour une
musique aujourd'hui me paraît très
détestable et ensuite que je crois plus
important
de ces d'éclairer les raisons pour
lesquelles on peut avoir telle ou telle
musique un jour parmi ses préférences
plutôt que
de les étaler comme ça au grand jour
donc pour moi l'essentiel dans la
musique n'est pas de faire un catalogue
ou une hiérarchie mais de réfléchir aux
conditions précises qui en font un
instrument de jouissance et je dirais
plutôt si vous voulez qu aujourd'hui la
musique que je préfère vient plutôt dans
celle que j'aime à jouer plutôt que
celle que j'aime à entendre ce qui
exclut définitivement toutes les
musiques qui ne sont pas à ma portée
pour en jouer c'est à dire les musiques
qui dépasse la capacité d'un seul
instrumentistes et ce qui renvoie
d'ailleurs en retour aux autres thèmes
que nous évoquions tout à l'heure car à
l'évidence le problème du rapport à eau
à la jouissance et à l'art dans les
sociétés d'aujourd'hui se pose de façon
radicalement différente de celle où elle
se posait il ya un siècle et exige donc
une année de référence théorique et un
débat d'une toute autre importance et
ampleur que celle dont on parle est
passée la 4e questionneur michel ca
professeur de philosophie à paris tu as
dit tout à l'heure que le livre que tu
fais ou le livre que tu as terminé
représenter pour toi du temps
cristalliser
cette très bonne référence
si le tas et cristallisé tu dois penser
très souvent à la mort qu'elle est en
rapport à la mort lorsque tu écris
c'est le rapport naïf de quelqu'un qui
essaye d'y échapper de façon permanente
et qui essaye d'échapper en de deux
façons d'une part en se disant que
lorsque j'aurais écrit je pourrais me
référer au temps passé parce qu'il aura
une existence matérielle et ensuite
parce que j'espère que ce temps durera
au delà de moi et que j'espère il durera
aussi dans l'action donc la mort est
partout présente et aussi peut-être
parce que la mort je la vis surtout
comme comme l' angoisse du silence
l'angoissent du silence et
l'impossibilité de
2,2 le meublé par moi même donc je
dirais que la mort et est à tout instant
peut-être et c'est une contradiction
quelque chose qui pousse à ne pas vivre
qu'est-ce que écrire c'est ne pas vivre
plutôt qui est quelque chose qui pousse
à vivre c'est-à-dire l'instant dans la
jouissance ce qui permettrait peut-être
de penser que entre la mort et la vie il
y a autre chose qui serait la vie dans
dans la no more ou laisser de
dépassement de la vie et de la mort dans
le temps cristallisé parlais tout à
l'heure du vieillissement de tapper de
calais quel est votre plus grande peur
je crois
qu'est ce que c'est pour toi mais ils
n'ont pas mourir mais vieillit la ccl
avoir moins de temps devant soi que
derrière soi et à l'imaginaire à du
temps concrets pour faire de temps
concrètement je vieillir cessé d'avoir
une probabilité d'avoir du temps d'être
pour construire une éternité ou une
durabilité plus brève devant soi que
derrière soi tu crois que les livres
sont éternels
je crois qu'ils sont plus importants
dans qu'ils peuvent être plus importants
dans la déterminer que quoi que ce soit
d'autre dans la mesure où ils sont
porteurs de quelque chose qui ressemble
à un code qui va structurer une
transformation sociale
voilà je crois que le code de
transformation enfin que le code qui
structurent des sociétés qui évoluent
est plus important que les sociétés
elles mêmes et que le livre c'est à dire
l'idée qui surnage circulent dans le
livre est peut être ce cas plus éternel
il suffit de regarder les écritures pour
sa prochaine sortie est maintenant
entrée d'un coeur du débat c'est à dire
ce qu'il est apparu à tout le gard dans
l'autoportrait
l'intellectuel et les pouvoirs ou le
pouvoir de l'intellectuel andré
glucksmann oui mais il ya une chose que
je comprends pas je connais jacques
attali depuis un mois je veux bien ne
tutoyez se laissait plutôt sympathique
mais je n'arrive pas à m'ôter de l'idée
que j'ai en face de moi le ministre de
l'économie du futur gouvernement de
gauche alors je sais bien qu'il ya 36
rebonds hommes qui se disputent ce poste
vous en étain entre d'autres et vous ne
vous le disputer peut-être même pas
d'ailleurs parce que mais de toute façon
vous êtes quand même le conseiller
économique de me tran
si vous n'êtes pas le ministre vous êtes
l'éminence grise
alors du coup tous eu tout ce dialogue
sur la mort et c'est terrain enfin hui
oui oui c'est gentil mais c'est un
ministre qui parle un futur ministre un
possible ministre et ceux qui a quand
même d extraordinaire c'est que nous
sommes dans la crise il ya un million de
chômeurs etc etc le socialisme c'est pas
joli joli dans la conscience des choses
parce que les gens ils appellent lure
socialiste s'il n'y a pas que la russie
il n'y a pas seulement 200 millions de
russes mais il ya là la majorité des
français pensent que la russie et
sociale si vous voulez changer leur
vocabulaire vous pouvez vous avez le
droit vous enseigner c'est votre boulot
mais moi j'ai créé des bouquins etc mais
au fond moi je respecte plus le
vocabulaire contre ils appellent ça
socialisme on a appelé ça socialisme ans
est réclamée not pourquoi pas l'appeler
comme ça alors je vous dis on est quand
même angoisse et pas seulement à cause
de la russie pas seulement à cause des
meurtres au cambodge pas seulement parce
que le xxème siècle c'est que c'est pas
le siècle de la technologie ou alors
vous appelez technologies les camps de
concentration c'est le siècle où il ya
650 millions de russes qui sont morts
brûlés c'est le siècle où en un an il ya
un million de cambodgiens qui sont
passés sans le son a sacré après après
le 1 million tué par les américains ce
qui est un plus beau donc on est on vit
là dedans et puis bon on a des dialogues
sur la mort sur les narcissisme et c'est
moi je j'admets mais je trouve que c'est
mieux quand c'est un poète qui parle ou
penser quand vous vous exprimez par des
poésies à la td là tout le monde nous
regarde on va pas pouvoir parler d'une
façon très très belle de la mort pas
très très belle de l'amour c'est plutôt
émouvant ce que vous dites c'est vrai
mais vous êtes quand même un personnage
qui a des responsabilités or vous fuyez
devant ses responsabilités
vous n'en parlez pas vous n'en dit pas
un mot on vous dit vous êtes socialiste
vous dites oui je suis socialiste mais
ya que moi qui sait de la signification
de ce mot moi seul je sais pas par quel
côté vous prendre mais je suppose que je
ne suis pas le seul jacques attali mais
socialisme est quelque chose qui
n'existe pas ou n'existe nulle part ça
c'est mon point de vue il n'ya aucun
pays qui peut se dire être
définitivement arriver à ce qu'on doit
appeler socialisme tout simplement parce
qu'il est immoral mais permettez je veux
dire par là qu'à mon avis ce dont nous
avons à ce à quoi nous avons à réfléchir
c'est à deux choses d'une part qu'est ce
qui est préférable comme avenir que
celui auquel conduit le capitalisme et
d'autre part que celui auquel peut
commencer a conduit en particulier dans
la france d'aujourd'hui un gouvernement
par la gauche et je crois que lorsqu'on
doit concevoir à penser à un choix entre
deux possibilités il faut imaginer les
deux à venir je pense que l'avenir tels
que prépare la droite française
aujourd'hui est quelque chose de
terrifiant comme aliénation comme
aménagement de la violence comme
contrôle policier comme insertion dans
un monde internationales dominées par
quelques grandes firmes comme
généralisation de la violence et qu'il
faut aussi penser ces catastrophes là
vous avez parlé du goulag je n'en suis
pas responsable
vous n'avez pas parlé des camps de
concentration je veux que la mission
américaine ou quand je parle des camps
de concentration nazis les camps de
concentration nazis sont aussi d'une
excroissance du capitalisme et les deux
ex 3 et c'est peut-être une imitation du
socialisme le nazi son ca national
socialisme et bien donc vous conservez
bien combien il peut y avoir des
usurpations de vocabulaire et combien
ces usurpations de vocabulaire ne nous
renseigne pas beaucoup pour ce que nous
avons à faire dirais donc que le rôle
d'un intellectuel qui se pense et qui se
veut aussi un homme d'action c'est de
bien participé à l'action pour faire en
sorte que cette action agissent sur les
bons leviers moi je crois que les bon
levier consiste à ne pas penser que face
à des pouvoirs qui sont les pouvoirs
économiques et financiers qui détermine
aujourd'hui la crise qu'il s'agisse des
grandes entreprises ou de la logique
même d'un système économique il ne faut
pas face à ces pouvoir opposer le simple
refus de ce que peut avoir une autre
direction du pouvoir je pense que face à
un pouvoir il faut prendre le pouvoir je
pense que face au pouvoir capitaliste il
faut prendre le pouvoir de façon
socialiste c'est à dire contrôler
l'appareil d'état et l'économie ça c'est
une réponse qui peut peut-être vous
paraître insuffisante je l'a
complètement neuf c'est celle de lénine
non je la complète en disant que prendre
le pouvoir n'est pas une finalité
prendre le pouvoir doit devenir un cessé
d'être une finalité pour être un moyen
et c'est l'état et la révolution ces
attaques de 50 ans c'est clair c'est
clair que la problématique a déjà été
essayée a été très souvent un échec
c'est clair que nous trouvant de voir
comment c'est clair que nous nous
trouvons devant une situation
complètement différente de celle dans
laquelle nous étions où il était à cette
période sauf que notre préoccupation
d'intellectuels ou tel que moi je le
pense devoir être la responsabilité
fondamentale des intellectuels ce n'est
pas d'aboyer de l'extérieur de la
caravane c'est d'essayer d'être dedans
pour prendre éviter qu'elles s'engagent
dans les marécages être dedans ça veut
dire penser effectivement les
conséquences et les moyens d'action sur
l'économie concrètes techniques telles
que nous sommes offert en sorte que le
pouvoir ne devienne pas une finalité
qu'à une bureaucratie capitalisme ne
succède pas une bureaucratie
technocratique c'est vrai ce que vous
dites mais c'est d'une telle évidence je
dirais qu'il faut aller beaucoup plus
loin et qu'il faut faire en sorte
d'essayer de le transformer le
transformer ça veut dire assumer le fait
qu'il faut d'abord prendre le pouvoir
pour faire en sorte qu ensuite le fait
de l'avoir pris ne soit pas une finalité
alors je réponds 1 face à la crise il
n'y a pas de solution de type
capitaliste sinon l'insertion plus
grande encore dans un monde de
domination et de bureaucratie qui
renvoie inévitablement à ce que michel
appelle une panacotta nato cratie c'est
à dire
le sorte de camp de concentration
généralisée dont l'exemple dont vous
avez parlé né parmi d'autre qu'un depuis
vingt ou trente siècles l'humanité n'a
pas commencé malheureusement les goulags
vers les années 20 dans un pays
asiatique elle les a commencé il y avait
des dizaines de siècles par tout ça n'a
rien à voir avec une mode
d'appropriation ça à voir avec ce que
l'humanité provoque comme mode de
régulation il ya des conceptions du bouc
émissaire qui sont général
transcendantale humanité non civilisés
et face auxquels il faut qu'en prenant
le pouvoir nous imaginions une
transformation je dis donc face à un
avenir capitaliste il n'y a pas d'autre
solution que parmi des avenirs
d'appropriation collective que ces
années en apoca d'appropriation
collective ne garantissent en rien que
ces transformations soit suffisante pour
créer les conditions de la liberté mais
que face à ces deux faces à 7,7 ce choix
là une fois qu'on a fait le choix de
refuser l'avenir capitaliste il faut de
l'intérieur penser des transformations
fondamentales penser qu'elles ne sont
pas que les nationalisations parmi pas
par exemple ne sont pas une finalité
mais un moyen si elles sont une finalité
alors on rentre dans la bureaucratie
d'état dont vous parlez si elles ne sont
qu'aux moyens il faut alors penser à des
transformations culturelles à une
démystification du pouvoir est ce que sa
centralité peut avoir mais je termine en
disant cette réponse à cette question
prenez garde
prenez garde que ce que l'apologie de la
jouissance pur dans la négation de la
reprise du pouvoir et sa concentration
qui a parlé de jouissance jeudi là
attendant prenez garde prenez garde
parce que ce genre d'interprétation
alors que le personne ne vous a parlé de
puissance pure me l'attribuer ce genre
de choses mène à des procès et vous êtes
en train de commencer un procès d'un
procès d'intention et oui mais des
procès ils y procèdent de procès en
procès on arrive assez vite à monsieur
vous il ya quelques années donc
commencer
oui moi je voudrais question double en
fait plutôt qu'une double question une
question double c'est eux vous nous
dites il faut être dans la caravane il
faut toujours être dans la caravane
enfin moi je vois pas la différence il
ya entre s'appuie la fameuse formulation
de morny faut toujours être du côté du
manche 1 et 2 vous ne m'avez toujours
pas répondu sur la raison pour laquelle
vous gardiez le terme de socialisme
alors que tout ce qu'on appelait au
monde socialisme c'est ce que glucksmann
a dit voilà bon mais je vais vous
répondre 2 il faut être dans la caravane
je crois aujourd'hui parce que la
situation d'un pays comme la france est
vraiment à la croisée des chemins où
dans les dix ans qui viennent ce pays
est définitivement satellisé dans un
monde
d'un environnement international de
nature capitaliste avec une
déculturation dont j'ai parlé un peu
tout à l'heure qui fait que ce pays et
l'europe en particulier perd
définitivement toute chance à une
culture autonome a une capacité créative
autonome a une capacité technologique
autonome a une capacité de vie concrète
autonome et les intellectuels parmi eux
parmi d'autres ne seront là que plus
encore qui ne sont aujourd'hui des
bouffons du roi lointain à l'étranger
qui ne parlons d'ailleurs même plus leur
langue donc je dis il faut être dedans
parce qu'aujourd'hui l'enjeu est
véritablement déterminant et que c'est
dedans tant dans l'organisation tels que
la gauche française se conçoit
aujourd'hui qu'il est possible il n'est
pas certain qu'il est possible de faire
que les changement soit effectif utile
pourquoi garder le mot de socialisme
mais je crois parce que le socialisme
est un beau mot qu'il renvoie encore
aujourd'hui à une utopie fondamentale
qui l'utopie de la
non agressivité générale de la solution
des problèmes hors de la violence qu'il
renvoie à la possibilité effective d'une
justice seront vraiment votre ahmadian
et bien alors vous êtes sexy même et ça
cela c'est ce que deutsche bahn vous
disais tout à l'heure enfin je tiens
vraiment dire qu'aujourd'hui c'est à sa
grand voile mot socialisme vous
m'accusiez tout à l'heure de faire de
l'archéologie parce que je suis un peu
d'histoire n'y a pas d'argent c'est bien
beau mais vous m'accusiez de faire de
l'archéologie enfin là qu'est ce que
vous faites au travail vous allez
bientôt envoyer potier dans la gueule ou
ou je ne sais qui en fait plus personne
ne pense que vous moi qui les avons lu
enfin socialisme à qui ça renvoie
aujourd'hui et vous osez me dit
l'idéologie de paix partout et cédera
alors que pour tout le monde qu'est ce
que c'est enfin le socialisme c'est
l'union soviétique le cambodge et ce qui
est hélas nous avons appris que la chine
nous qui fument gros chinois de fait ce
n'est pas ma faute si vous avez pensé
qu'il existe je ne regrette pas
ça n'est pas ma faute ce n'est pas ma
faute si vous avez pensé un jour ce que
moi pour ma part je suis tout à fait
serein et tranquille je n'ai jamais
pensé que cela dit c'est à dire qu'il
existe des modèles du socialisme moi je
suis tout à fait serein et tranquille je
n'ai jamais cru qu'il en existait alors
que vous vous éprouvez le pen le
complexe un peu de d'avoir perdu votre
père donc oui
il a fait gratuitement non mais je dirai
ce que ces produits dans votre livre en
entier économique vous dites qu'il ya
plusieurs stratégies l'une celle que
vous condamnez du capitalisme comme s'il
y avait une seule stratégie du
capitalisme ce qui est quand même assez
douteux
oui deuxièmement vous dites qu'il ya une
autre stratégie vous citer des exemples
là malheureusement vous donner des noms
alors vous donnez cuba vous donnez la
tanzanie j'ai rien contre la tanzanie
cuba s'est quand même économiquement
actuellement une colonie soviétique
c'est pas un modèle modèle et puis vous
donner la chine fait les homosexuels et
vous des cailloux et vous donner la
chine alors là où les homosexuels se
font tuer et c'est
bien alors pour ce qui est du prochain
chinois où personne n'a rien dit je dois
le plat c'est vrai que là tout à fait
sincère bras vous dis-je avallon
socialisme c'est simplement pour vous un
mot que vous donner le droit de définir
comme une utopie parce que dans vos
livres vous dit quand même que ça existe
sérieusement qu'il y a une stratégie
alternative ce n'est que bien sûr cette
stratégie alternative ce n'est pas cette
des chinois ce n'est pas celle des
cubains ce n'est pas cette détente année
mais malgré tout quand on regarde du
côté de la chine du côté de la tanzanie
du côté de cuba c'est intéressant et ça
montre bien qu'il ya autre chose à faire
alors là moi je regarde moi aussi c'est
terrifiant c'est terrifiant ce que vous
dites parce que vous parlez d'un livre
dont je suppose que personnes qui nous
écoutent ne la lui est en tout cas vous
le déformées de telle façon que ça
ressemble beaucoup au procès de vous
fait qu'elle vous faites allusion tout à
l'est qu'est ce que j'ai dit dans ce
livre à un chapitre très précis où je
parlais uniquement d'un problème
particulier qui était celui de
l'inégalité et je disais face au
problème de la croissance il y a deux
moteurs possible dans une économie
marchande il y a un moteur qui est
l'inégalité poussant comme moteur de
croissance et un moteur qui est
l'égalité où la croissance est portée
par d'autres valeurs que l'inégalité où
l'individualisme et je donner deux
exemples des exemples des deux domaines
mais vous remarquerez que je n'ai jamais
dit qu'il faut penser le deuxième type
de développement comme étant un modèle
pour nous je n'ai jamais jamais dit
qu'il n'y avait rien à prendre dans les
premiers et tout apprendre dans les
secondes je pense pour ma part qu'il y a
dans les pays capitalistes modernes des
éléments qui sont en train peu à peu de
mettre en place quelque chose qui va
ressembler aux socialistes je pense que
le socialisme vient après le capitalisme
et non pas à la place comme un raccourci
dans le capitalisme je pense qu'il ya
beaucoup de germes de socialisme nouveau
à prendre dans les expériences dans les
mutations dans les transformations
culturelles qui se passe en particulier
dans les jeux jeunesse américaine ou
dans les jeunesses française je pense
donc qu'il ne faut pas penser je pense
donc je pense que ce n'est pas notre
problème
mais moi notre problème n'est pas à
conserver bien que de mon point de vue
l'essentiel de ce que nous avons à faire
c'est de penser effectivement ce que
dans dans l'europe d'aujourd'hui et
c'est un problème intellectuel d'une
difficulté fantastique il faut faire
pour éviter la généralisation de la
bureaucratie le capitalisme cause le
capitalisme le capitalisme d'aujourd'hui
conduit inévitablement au capitalisme
d'état
c'est le capitalisme d'aujourd'hui dans
sa logique non inquiétant c'est le
capitalisme à 12 ans la caravane ne
l'êtes dans cette caravane le
capitalisme d'état que gmail en
attention et excusez moi c'est justement
parce que j'ai nous avons la nuit et
j'ai la lucidité par bidaude à sa
boutique d'analyser l'évolution du
capitalisme conduisant inévitablement à
une bureaucratie d'état qu'il faut dès
aujourd'hui penser et le concept d'auto
gestion à cela qu'il porte la négation
de la bureaucratie d'état qu'il faut
bien penser contre le capitalisme c'est
à dire par la définition de son
adversaire fondamentale du mot
antinomiques et socialisme la définition
de l'autre société qui permettra seul
d'éviter le capitalisme d'état pourquoi
est ce que j'écris sur la musique parce
que je pense fondamentalement qu'il faut
cesser de réfléchir uniquement aux
transformations en termes de propriété
économiques qu'elles sont évidemment
dans l'appropriation culturelle raison
mais faites le donc aussi commencé à
penser autrement qu'en termes de
négation du socialisme tel que c'est ce
que vous appelez ailleurs
que monsieur malek monsieur serre qui je
crois aussi des questions à poser à
jacques attali alors michel serres
de la mort tu as dit que c'était bien
gentil de parler de la mort mais j'ai
quand même lui délivre nixon et c'est
quand même aussi ton problème c'est pas
le problème de la mort personnel de la
mort individuel
c'est la mort des autres mais quand je
parle de la mort je n'en parle pas comme
un poète intimiste quand j'ai quand même
écrit la thanatopraxie et cédera donc
c'est
oui non mais alors précisément elle la
question la question que je posais
jacques attali sur la mort n'était pas
une question simplement quel est ton
pathétique ou quel est ton sentiment
face à ta mort individuel c'était aussi
le problème de savoir comment se situe
par rapport à la mort des autres
commente situer par rapport à la
politique définie en gros con le pouvoir
défini en gros comme monopole de la
violence auquel cas effectivement
c'est la même question mais mais c'est
c'est une manière aussi de de lier tout
le dialogue répondre à cette question
parce que c'est pas un problème
pathétique personne c'est plus à ça
c'était la poésie du 19e siècle je vais
je n'ai jamais pensé je suis partante la
réflexion divo malek qui a réagi à une
chose que vous avez dit tout à l'heure
des questions qui se veulent quand même
un peu lié la musique évidemment pas
l'excusé salaires extrêmement déplacé
dans ce débat nous avait lancé je la
maison cadeau si les mains non non non
je ne pense pas et je ne pense pas de sa
sphère déplacer je voudrais poser la
question suivante puisque on a parlé de
la caravane puisqu'on a parlé vous dites
qu'il faut être dedans
et vous parlait d'autre part du pouvoir
nous avons effectivement dans nos
pratiques musicales nous avons une
question historique de la
hiérarchisation
c'est là librement acceptée par les
pratiquants autrement le système qui est
un système
vous passez le mot libéral parce que je
considérais que là s'il ya quelque chose
qui est une révolution permanente c'est
bien la musique mais là dans ce système
il y a il y a un un rituel six volets
hiérarchique dont nous cherchons vous
aujourd'hui à nous débarrasser peu à peu
or il se trouve que chaque fois on veut
lâcher le pouvoir ça pose de difficultés
et 9 passes du côté de celui qui veut
lâcher le pouvoir mais du côté de celui
qui la subit
eh bien le pouvoir entre guillemets maaf
à l'image est transmissible si vous
voulez sur les questions dont nous
parlons comment imaginez vous une fois
arrivé au pouvoir a lâché ce pouvoir
s'en débarrasser
et
finalement si vous voulez ne pas en
faire une chose en soi
notre façon sur la musique de retourner
à la la même question il est clair à mon
sens que
une société qui ces programmes et comme
elle c'est programmé jusqu'à aujourd'hui
faut faire de l' attente de la réponse
du pouvoir à vos problèmes une sorte de
réflexe conditionné ne peut pas du jour
au lendemain l'abandonner c'est pas
possible c'est serait l'abandonner à de
nouveaux maîtres il est clair qu'on voit
bien sur des expériences musicales quand
on donne des instruments des gens il
attend d'un chef ou trop souvent il est
clair donc l'idée de ce qu'il faut
opposer au capitalisme une stratégie de
l'anarchisme de négation du pouvoir
c'est en fait ouvrir grandes les portes
à la dictature donc il est clair qu'il
ne faut pas se contenter de nier le
pouvoir en tant que tel et c'est en cela
qu'il y avait raccourci sur la nouvelle
droite pendant petit film de tout à
l'heure c'est que ni et le pouvoir en
tant que tel et se contenter de le nier
ne vouloir le nier c'est ouvrir tout
droit à la porte aux dictatures tout
droit
alors sur ce que disait michel moi je
voudrais dire un mot parce que c'est
très c'est très important et ça ouvre
des questions auxquelles j'avoue ne pas
avoir de réponse
la question de la mort organisée bon
qu'est ce que c'est qu'aujourd'hui
l'essentiel dames organisé c'est la
course aux armements et le stockage de
la mort il faut bien voir ce que ça
signifie que ce stockage la main moi je
crois que ça renvoie à une chose
fondamentale c'est que nos sociétés sont
économiquement organisé sur le stockage
de tous le stockage de tous qui a
transmis à remplacer la jouissance des
choses on a remplacé la jouissance des
choses par le stockage de leurs de leur
image et que comme on n'a pas réussi à
organiser le stockage individuel de la
mort on en a fait un stockage collectif
et il est clair aussi qu'il semble que
dans cette logique on ne pourrait
substituer au stockage collectif de la
mort un stockage individuel que si on
donnait aux gens ont les moyens de
stocker des armes etc donc il est donc
évident que la course aux armements
renvoie à quelque chose de très profond
dans nos sociétés qui est l'accumulation
de la marchandise l'accumulation des
objets comme une finalité l'oubli
définitif de toute forme de
ritualisation sociales et toutes formes
de canalisation de la violence autre que
celle que prend l'armement aujourd'hui
mais qu'est-ce qu'il faut répondre à ça
est-ce qu'il faut se contenter d'un
discours sur le bouc émissaire est ce
qu'il faut se contenter d'un discours
sur la négation du pouvoir et se
lamenter sur ou est ce qu'il faut penser
concrètement à participer à une
transformation est ce que dans 30 ans
lorsqu'après que tout aura été détruits
par des violences généralisées
on dira aux intellectuels comme vous
aviez raison de dire que c'était affreux
les goulags ou est ce qu on leur dira et
comme vous avez été traître de ne pas
penser à une stratégie pour éviter ces
morts là moi je crois que c'est
difficile d'éviter de prendre le pouvoir
pour un intellectuel je crois que c'est
très difficile d'ajouter 30 parce que
c'est
c'est vrai qu'il ne suffit pas de dire
c'est un troll moulin encore faut-il le
dire pendant cinquante ans le parti
connu ces conseils ne l'a pas tu es
maintenant il dit qu'il l'a toujours dit
que ce qui reste quand même quelque
chose de pas dit c'est son problème
jitsu pas qu il est d'accord c'est votre
avis bon passons
de fait le problème c'est celui du
concret si vous prenez par exemple le
stockage du pouvoir la monopolisation du
pouvoir et si vous partez pas trop loin
de la musique quand même un peu excusez
moi
vous vous rendez compte que il ya un
stockage une monopolisation de la parole
et aussi de la possibilité de publier
des maîtres de la musique dans nos
sociétés
bon pour être très franc et très très
précis il ya une modification concrètes
très facile à faire en france à l'heure
actuelle dans notre société et à mon
avis vous pouvez la faire vous jacques
attali et vos amis me tran etc c'est de
donner la parole à ceux qui risqueraient
de
l'employé d'une façon inattendue est
pour vous et pour moi parce que nous
sommes malgré tout des intellectuels des
privilégiés vous comme des jeunes cadres
imaginer qu'ils aient des radios dans
les quartiers imaginez que le monopole
de la radio et de la télévision mais
disons d'abord de la radio soit brisée
il l'est en italie il l'est plus ou
moins aux états unis etc imaginez que
les collectivités aient la possibilité
de s'exprimer dans les quartiers à mon
avis il y aurait quelque chose de
transformer au niveau même du pouvoir je
pense or que c'est pas contre vous que
je dis
il y aurait quelque chose de transformer
au niveau du pouvoir ne serait-ce que
par l'exemple classique c'est que quand
il ya un coup d'état qu'est ce qu'on
prend en premier c'est la maison de la
radio et on passe des déserts
patriotique des champs de l'armée bon
alors s'il y a quelque chose à faire là
pourquoi vous qui est le premier parti
de france vous qui avez la puissance
malgré tout de mobiliser l'opinion vous
qui pouvez le faire aujourd'hui
maintenant et qu'il pouvait le dire
maintenant à la télévision devant tout
le monde que c'est ça la solution qu'il
faut briser le monopole que le parti
socialiste dès que quelqu'un consacrera
le prix de deux de chevaux 2 2 chevaux
rien de plus à construire un poste
émetteur et à le faire fonctionner sur
un quartier que le parti socialiste
défendra ce quelqu'un et le défendra
contre la police et contre toute
tentative du gouvernement ça
transformerait la france a relevé très
grande partie à une des questions du
pouvoir pourquoi vous ne le fait pas
aujourd'hui
un formidable question d'abord vous
voyez bien combien à ceux ci exigent
pour le faire d'être au pouvoir donc il
faudra du tout mais c'est moi laissez
moi d'habitude avéré neuner ger plus des
seconds immense deuxièmement je ne je
n'admets pas qu'on dise vous parti
socialiste à quelqu'un individuellement
même s'il en est et ce que je ne suis
pas responsable c'est rentrer dans le
jeu du goulag que de personnaliser des
individus dans une institution c'est
anonymisées des individus je ne suis pas
et personne ne parle comme s'il était
une institution c'est admettre
définitivement la bureaucratie je suis
un individu chacun des individus est un
individu sauf s'il parle au nom d'une
élection d'un vote d'un bureau politique
ce que je n'ai pas nous donc
photographier leurs côtés d'un autre
individu par aller en soit mis trois
relais à un individu qui vous répond 1
comme un individu sinon vous entrez dans
un jeu terriblement
dramatique et destructeur je continue
sur la question vous avez posé reconnais
c'est d'abord un qu'il faut avoir fait
l'analyse que je partage complètement
avec vous que le réseau centralisé
faisceau de pouvoir est à détruire au
niveau de la radio mais penser une chose
penser que pour le faire concrètement
pour éviter que cette stratégie de
destruction du réseau santé ral soient
repris à son compte par un autre réseau
central qui est le réseau économique et
financier il faut quoi il faut non
seulement avoir les moyens de permettre
que soit organisée une destruction du
monopole d'état pour permettre les
régions et les collectivités indépendant
mais il faut avoir aussi ensuite les
moyens d'empêcher que les radios
commerciales qui représente l'essentiel
du pouvoir financier aujourd'hui créé
face à une seule radio de collectivités
locales ou d'individus qui aura rompu le
monopole 300 stations privées
commerciales qui viendront aggraver
l'aliénation face à un pouvoir vous ne
pouvez pas naïvement pensé une minuscule
contre-pouvoir sinon vous n'avez pas les
moyens centraux d'empêcher que le
pouvoir ancien généraliste son pouvoir
face à ce prétexte est la raison pour
laquelle à mon sens c'est aujourd'hui
seulement par est ce parce que si on
avait heureusement et le site on
n'aurait pas eu la bataille sur
l'avortement on n'aurait jamais fait ça
du civoire conduit à coire qui conduit à
quoi à penser qu'aujourd'hui il faut
absolument créer une multitude de
liberté de parole d'entrée c'est clair
mais il faut aussi avoir les moyens
d'empêcher que cette parole soit
détournée il ya donc des contrôles à
l'ancien pouvoir ou par le nouveau
pourquoi est ce que nous voulions douar
lui ne tournerait pas quelles garanties
nous donnez vous mais quelle garantie
avons nous que jacques attali sera
meilleur que giscard d'estaing quelles
garanties c'est pas au niveau individuel
vous parler vraiment de façon d'annoncer
que je parle
excusez moi non mais elles servent poser
une question dernière non gallardo
30 secondes alors confisqué comme les
pouvoirs ont toujours fait pourquoi le
boire parce que nouveau ce qui est impur
signifiant comme ceinture non un pur
adjectif pourquoi le pouvoir parce que
nouveau ne ferai pas ce que les poumons
ont touché les chiens je n'ai jamais
gêné vous pourriez vous l'avez pas dit
vous ne donnez pas bien mais je ne veux
pas mais bien sûr que non mais il n'y a
pas de garantie pourquoi voulez-vous que
moi qui ne représente qu'un intellectuel
puisse donner qui est qui que ce soit
comment voulez vous avoir de guerre de
croire comment voulez-vous zone et
comment voulez vous qu'une institution
donne des garanties 30 secondes
allez-vous qu'une institution donne des
garanties à ce qui ne dépend que ce qu
des individus et des groupes à la base
voudront bien défendre voulait entrer
dans le jeu de la digue michel serres un
dernier mot l'histoire de la
communication une très bonne question de
glucksmann et je crois que la réponse a
été a été bonne et la garante qui posait
sans qu'on la voit passer savoir que
premièrement ya il ya une idée en
faisceaux c'est-à-dire il ya un point
central de communication générale et
puis il ya un modèle un réseau où tout
car ce prix elle cédera bon non c'est un
réseau centralisme c'est plus mal on se
tait
aujourd'hui tout de suite le parti
socialiste est assez puissant en france
pour que s'ils créent une radio il brise
le monopole le monople est brisée
jacques évasives ou d'en demander plus
si vous en demander plus vous instaurer
de nouveaux fric d'un nouveau contrôleur
de nouveaux cadres de nouveaux encadré
votre raisonnement me paraît est un
petit chef totalement à court terme et
conduit inévitablement un renforcement
du pouvoir de la marchandise et de
l'aliénation consommatoire en
conséquence on vous fait confiance et
c'est non faites une analyste et excusez
moi vous l avez dit les aboyeurs un
sartre pendant la guerre d'algérie il a
peut-être aboyer et mitrand il était
peut-être aux tenants de la caravane
mais mitrand il a dit algérie française
et il a envoyé des troupes en algérie et
sartre aboyant n'étant pas au dedans de
rien a quand même contribué à la
résistance à la guerre d'algérie et je
dis que si à cette époque qu'il y avait
eu des postes il y aurait peut-être eu
dix postes commerciaux et un seul poste
populaire et bien malgré tout on aurait
pu organiser mieux des manifestations
sur la carte est un mode réponse de
jacques attali je suis très triste
michel serres impression amour je suis
très triste parce que je crois que
l'essentiel de ce que les intellectuels
ont à faire c'est de penser les
changements d'aujourd'hui les
changements at elle une nécessité de
connaître la réalité économique du
capitalisme moderne qui n'a rien à voir
avec ce que la philosophie enseignée
autant de marx il faut connaître la
réalité du capitalisme moderne c'est
très compliqué ça exige d'apprendre
deuxièmement et deuxièmement
deuxièmement je crois que lorsqu'on
mélange comme malheureusement de redux
mains deviennent le fait des fêtes avec
des calomnies et des simplifications se
range dans l'ancienne droite
10 l'an dernier et qu'il a dit algérie
française messieurs à fond j'ai
terminé je vous remercie beaucoup
[Musique]